en este vídeo les presentaré una manera
alterna de hacer mentalmente las restas
no la tienen que ocupar pero si les
funciona bienvenidos yo se las muestro
porque a mí me funciona y tal vez a
ustedes les pueda ayudar a entender todo
esto es una manera rápida para mí ok
veamos si tenemos 9.456 7.589 sin duda
este es mayor que éste por lo tanto
podremos hacer nuestra resta lo que me
gusta pensar y utilizando los colores
que hemos usado para unidades de millar
decenas centenas y unidades será lo
siguiente si a estos dos números yo les
restó siete mil y estoy tomando el siete
mil por este siete ok
tendremos que este siete se eliminará
siete mil 589 siete mil 589 pero también
ocupó restárselo aquí nueve mil 456
menos siete mil va a ser dos mil 456
vamos bien
hagamos ahora lo siguiente con las
centenas si estos dos números les restó
500 y lo estoy sacando de aquí este 500
tendremos lo siguiente 589 500 se
elimina el 500 y sólo nos queda 89 y se
lo vamos a quitar aquí encima a este 2
mil 456 que fue nuestro último saldo lo
más sencillo es dividirlo hasta donde
vamos y si a 24 le quito 5 es igual a 19
1956 que de hecho 2 mil 456 menos 500
son 1956 vamos bien
siguiente columna
si a 89 le quito 80 considerando este 8
89 menos 80 es igual a 9 solo me queda
el 9 pero de la misma manera se lo
restará a este último número que nos
había quedado
vuelvo a dividir y si a 195 le quito 8
me quedan 187
y vuelva a manejar el 6 y entonces todo
se vuelve más sencillo porque sólo tengo
dos números 1876 - 9
se dan cuenta y 1876 - 9 de 1867
este es mi resultado de cualquier manera
vamos a hacer la resta de la manera
original para que vean que estamos en lo
correcto 9.456 menos 7 mil 589 lo
haremos rápidamente como lo solemos
manejar
6 - 9 ocupa que pidamos prestado 1 este
se vuelve un 4
y este se vuelve un 16
el 4 es menor que el 8 por lo que vamos
a pedir también este se vuelve un 3
y este se vuelve un 14 porque estamos
tomando prestado y 9 menos 7 es más
grande el 9 por lo que no habrá problema
ahora podemos hacer nuestra resta 16
menos 9 es igual a 7 14 14 menos 8 es
igual a 6
3 - 5 así vamos a tener que pedir
prestado disculpen ustedes vamos a pedir
prestado entonces y este 9 se vuelve 8 y
éste se volvió en 13
13 - 5 es igual a 8
y 87 es igual a 1 tenemos exactamente el
mismo resultado les digo puede funcionar
les o no anime me ayuda a nivel mental
si a ustedes les agrada esta explicación
bienvenidos si no les funciona pues
siempre pueden seguir haciendo esto o
reagrupar recuerden por unidades de
millar centenas decenas o unidades y de
esa manera llegaremos de forma adecuada
a nuestro resultado
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo